people started going I'm sick of work
I'm working all day long
sacrificing my family when you sacrifice
what you love for Success you get
neither instead of saying
I'm gonna do one thing slit in the
future I'll get something else you say
no I want that thing now not in a
selfish way because you honor the time
you have on Earth dude it's beautiful so
it's not about time management it's not
about controlling your time it's about
who controls your time
well I'm so excited to get into this
conversation and talk about kind of like
uh your book essentially anti-tan time
management and how work-life balance
just isn't working anymore and so what
are some of like the things that have
led up to this consensus that you've
come up with well let me tell you this
like balance is a great word but it
doesn't work for work and life and the
reason the reason is because balance and
physics literally means motionless
balance means you don't move it means
stagnant it means stale but we try it to
put it up as this thing that's success
it's never been that way it never will
be that way until you're dead that the
greatest balance in life is death
and so the idea isn't always trying to
figure out how does like how do I get
you know this many hours of sleep in
this many hours of whatever right
is dynamic you want to be able to have
like in basketball you want the ball to
move forward in the direction you want
it to go that requires imbalance that
requires pushing that requires that
requires trajectory and so the idea of
anti-time management is this
if you go back in history time
management actually has a very dark past
it was never designed to give people
their time and their freedom back it was
designed specifically as a tool to
control others it was designed to
measure every drop of Blood Sweat and
Tears from workers facts and you go like
wow why do we use it in self-help
vernacular I don't know but I do know
that once managers and leaders started
realizing people could manage their own
time instead of someone else doing it
they thought they could get more out of
people wow has nothing to do with
personal freedoms I I can't stress it
time management has zero to do
with personal happiness productivity or
or even money it is all for the
corporation once you realize that you
know what's the solution you know and I
call it anti-type management but I did
this because like in short
I wrote my last book The Power of
starting something stupid people will
start their stupid idea their new
project the new idea their new video
their new podcast they they write their
new article they do their new book they
do the next pose
it's not what they wanted they didn't
want the thing they were doing they
wanted what they thought would come from
the success well of the thing they were
doing it's a two-step I'll do this and
then I'll do that
if you can just jump over like people
are obsessed with goals habits and
strengths those are tools
they're not ends we've made them ends
unto themselves so you can jump past
that and go
what's the job of the goal what's the
job of the Habit what's the job of these
strengths that I have and you get there
and you can work in a way that creates a
moat to support your time protect your
time protect your family protect your
availability protect your ability to do
whatever you want whenever you want when
you work endlessly toward a goal you
never get it that's anti-time management
that's beautiful and why would you
actually say why has balance become
bigger than I would I mean I kind of go
with rhythm like it's rhythm's a great
word yeah but why has balance been the
word that has been accepted and and kind
of the goal I think it's just
misunderstood you know it's a great word
and if you if you really were to dive
into like when it started being used in
this way
well yeah people started going I'm sick
of work I'm working all day long
sacrificing my family
when you sacrifice what you love
for Success you get neither
come on so when that happened people
were like oh I need to be able to
balance I need to I need a seesaw I need
to be able to go there and come back and
you know what there's a case for that
but not this does it not always happen
rarely if ever people don't want that
they want their life moving forward they
want things to happen they want to be
able especially today in the 21st
century they want to be able to think
and create and not do the things they
don't want to do not because they're
lazy but because their time can be spent
better somewhere else so you know things
have changed but I'll tell you this like
I'll get super real
I had a brother-in-law pass away at the
age of 21.
and when that happened I mean that shook
us like it changed everything about the
way we thought about time and life is
short but it's not some cliche like it's
a real thing and some might go yeah life
is long and you go well I guess it
depends what perspective you're looking
at you know like right sitting in a room
where it's boring is a very long time
even though it might be only a couple
minutes you know yeah
but a few years later my uh our fourth
son he caught pertussis also known as
whooping cough he also passed away
and so I had these these two we named
him Gavin after my brother-in-law Gap we
have these two Gavins buried in Hawaii
that's where I live and we visit these
Graves all the time it's become my kids
playground it's a bizarre thing to say
but it's a real thing and when you when
you when you come up thinking like oh my
gosh I might not live that long it
changes when you work why you work how
you work instead of saying
I'm going to do one thing so that in the
future I'll get something else you say
no I want that thing now not in a
selfish way because you honor the time
you have on Earth dude it's beautiful so
it's not about time management it's not
about
controlling your time it's about who
controls your time
dude
let's get practical in the sense of like
what would be like step one uh would you
say when it comes to getting your time
back and or you know defining who it is
that controls my time let's say step
step one would really be to kind of step
back and a step back is not a step
backwards it's almost like a step up so
you can kind of see that whole vision
360.
meaning I call it like a like it's like
a medical
so when you realize that what you're
doing is really for something else and
you go okay that's something else that's
what I want that's my purpose and you
can have multiple purposes
professional personal people play I call
it the four P's okay and then you look
at those and you go
well to make that thing happen whatever
I'll talk General and then we can get
specific to make that thing happen
what's my priority because you got to
understand in kindergarten we were
taught goals and priorities like this
yeah hey I'm going to give you a Jelly
Bean at the end of the day
that had nothing to do with the Jelly
Bean that was about the teacher
controlling the children
you're not going to get a Jelly Bean if
you don't do that thing and we've used
that methodology throughout our entire
lives that's not the way life works you
could have freaking had the job right
now the whole time and you still could
have been
you know doing your thing without having
to be controlled yeah
so priorities mean you have to rescue
your dream from the end of a timeline
and bring it front and center
so now you have like these four purposes
you create four priorities that align
them
create four projects
and I'm going faster
but imagine you have four projects and
you overlapped them
priority overlap one decision can make
all four happen at the same time so for
example I wanted to work for my cell
phone this is a long time ago
this is this is a long time ago okay
this is when phones fold it
all right but the reason was if I can
work for my cell phone it becomes what's
inside psychology called a forcing
function
I told myself
if I could figure out a way to work
differently if I can figure out a way to
get paid differently My Lifestyle would
change nothing changes your lifestyle
more than changing how you get paid you
can be unhealthy and still have to go to
work you can have a bad relationship and
still have to go to work right but if
how your paid isn't tied to a chair you
can go anywhere and do anything yep
right okay so this is all important so
then you create projects so imagine you
have your let's make it real a podcast
and you have your YouTube channel and
you have these other socials and you
have email and you have your family and
maybe you have maybe you have like a
real job or a contractor job they're all
real jobs right but one where they're
telling you where to go maybe all these
things
is there a way for these things to fit
together
where they can't you have decisions to
make where they can you can blend them
so I ended up on the road with my family
for six months from New York to San
Diego to Mexico to Canada back to Hawaii
making money on the road all the money
will be made on the road we spent on the
road in other words we weren't like
living off some
some some big fun we didn't weren't
using credit cards or or other weird
things there's a way to be able to make
money from anywhere
and do the things that you want if you
want to be able to pick up your kids
from school in the morning and bring
them home at night if you want to coach
your kids sports go on do that and then
you will be smarter in the way you
organize your life you already know this
we already know this works because most
people go I'm going to do these 10
things and the 11th step I'm going to
make the magic happen
but the 11th step usually never happens
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
so what we do is we go why don't I focus
on that thing that there it is and work
from the goal instead of endlessly
toward it so in that sense goals from
experience are are merely tasks you
already know how to do them
goals from
outside your experience are growth you
don't know how to do them so in this way
you can do whatever you want however you
want you can Outsource you can delegate
you can create things whoever's
listening to this despite challenges
despite a hardship despite terrible
things that may happen in their world
grief is a tunnel not a cave
and grief is a hard thing to go through
and you can find all kinds of ways to
support the life you want to live
without waiting another day for someone
to save you because that person doesn't
always come you know what I mean yeah
yeah so you say step one is to step back
and it's not going backwards but it's
just to get a good idea and start
planning I think a good word there is
like pre-deciding like just choosing
pre-deciding is so important yeah no
that's a great word that's a really good
word the reason that's a good word is
because I mean think about someone who
doesn't want to
let's just make it simple for someone to
understand you don't want to eat sugar
so you tell yourself I'm going to go to
this party but I'm not going to eat
sugar well you're tempted by you know
you eat it whatever but if you really
say I am a person that doesn't eat sugar
you're more likely than not you know to
to not to not do it so when you
pre-decide when you get in situations
they're hard
at work and whatever else yeah so what
would you say is step two into getting
that back or getting that control back
so the step step one you know stepping
back and figuring out step two would be
stepping
into it you kind of step up and then you
step in and you step in by actually
doing it so instead of saying I will one
day I am now
think of the life
between two different people two
different people could have the same job
same goal same dream same exact things
right one will have all the time in the
world to hang out with their family and
the other will have a zero it's because
of the way they work so you step into it
by saying
I am a runner is a very different life
than I will be a runner yeah I am
healthy is a very different life than I
will be healthy one day I am making
money as a Creator is a very different
opportunity life decision than saying I
will one day so you step in and then the
third step from that would be because
you've now found your voice you figured
out a way to do it this is this is so
key
as people start to grow
they start to get really frustrated
because
they find themselves in a role that they
don't want and they've never learned
that in leadership it's not about
managing or micromanaging the goal is to
delegate results not methods that's good
when you delegate results not methods
that inherently means you're you're
working with people I call it expert
sourcing that know what they're doing
that don't necessarily even need to be
trained yeah this changes everything
right for sure okay so so once you once
you work towards this what you find is
as you found your voice you can help
others find theirs because every person
that's found their voice has a unique
ability to have others find theirs right
when others finds there's you create
this ecosystem of Life of work of quote
unquote balance or rather an imbalance
in the direction you want it to go
that's like none other yeah I can give
you Millions that's beautiful I mean I
think what something I've learned in
leadership is extending trust like
initially I think a lot of times people
think that you have to earn your trust
yes but you can move so much faster by
trusting and let them mess it like you
get to decide if I have to retreat from
from what I'm absolutely empowering you
to do I agree and have you ever gotten
burned for sure sure me too and it's
like I'd rather get burned
nine times out of ten and get one that
really works then to never try at all
right now it doesn't feel good and you
might start getting smarter and better
at who you trust and when and how and
where but when you trust first I'm with
you 100 imagine somebody just as good
with what you're saying when you feel
like someone doesn't trust you how do
you act it's weird you know it's hard to
how do I act if I don't feel like
someone trusts me that's the way we have
to work with all kinds of people is is
begin with trust that's beautiful man so
what would you say is like your hope
what do you feel like what would you
hope that people just would grasp from
the message of your book ultimately let
me give you a quick story I I grew up in
I grew up in San Diego and when I was 16
and I wanted money you know aren't as
many that's what you are right and my
dad goes he goes I go Dad I want a job
because he don't want a job I'm like
what do you mean I don't want a job like
what do you like where's Dad ever how
could you say something like that you
know you're supposed to tell me to get a
job he goes no no no it was summertime
and he goes like well I still want money
and he said that he said go to El Centro
which is like three hours away from from
where I lived and it's uh where the
Farms are so go to El Centro take the
family van take the seats out of the car
go with your little brother who was I
was 16 he was 14. and we go all the way
to L Center he says ask the watermelon
Farmers if you can buy their irregular
sized watermelons that they can't sell
to the grocery stores
and we did and we brought him home and
we sold them to our friend's parents and
we sold them you know on at the park and
we did all these things
we made more money in one day than we
would have made working minimum wage the
entire summer that's insane I didn't
think much about until until even more
recently
and I started writing the book I started
looking back and I was like that really
was like an incredible mind set shift
for me that's a thinking different yeah
so sometimes we think we know what we
want but sometimes having a mentor who
can open up our minds I could have never
thought of that on my own right but a
mentor who can say here's how you do it
here's a cool way here's how I I've done
it here's a creative way and if you're
willing to do the work and make it
happen not only will that thing work out
and even if it doesn't it will change
the way you think about your
opportunities
this message is about thinking
differently you know after my my
brother-in-law passed away my son passed
away we had three foster kids that came
and went and it was sad to see them go
there's a reason they were in our home
you know what I mean my wife had a
stroke and lost her memory she got it
back okay all right my my son got hit by
a car should be dead he's okay he kind
of sees himself now as Superman like he
beat the car you know what I mean like
it's a cool mindset for him
I remember one day I thought does God
hate me like what's going on right now
you know and I thought
all these things are happening they're
not necessarily happening to me but
they're attached to me because of all
these people that I love
and then I thought it was an interesting
thought I never thought of before I had
this this little conversation in my head
that said
love God unconditionally
and to me that meant
keep your faith do your thing don't
blame you know the daddy in the sky
every time something goes wrong because
then all emotions go up and down and
focus on what you can control what you
can do and go back love your family you
know do these things and that's been a
powerful message because I learned that
how you spend your time is how you show
your love
and if you're constantly spending your
time trying to do something to get
something else
how are you showing your love to those
people around you so good and when you
procrastinate I'm not I'm not against it
you just remember what it can be used as
a positive tool because no one's more
productive than procrastinator with an
impending deadline you know what I'm
saying
so if you know that about yourself you
can live your life and you can create
systems modes processes to protect it
instead of sacrificing your life for
work and never getting your life back
because that's people's plan on purpose
yeah wrongly flipping around man that's
so good yeah I've heard it uh that
people spell love t-i-m-e oh that's good
especially kids you know learning that I
have a young daughter but that's huge
man A.W Tozer says um what you think
about when you think about God is the
most important thing about you
interesting and your concept of God I
just want to commend you you know
there's so much of of scripture you know
uh the Book of James says count it all
joy when we Face trials of many kinds
because it produces something in us and
I I see a fruitful life in in your life
even just the joy I get when when you
know look at look at this guy's smiling
you know always smiling laughing through
telling these stories I'm like dude
[Music]
bro life's crazy dude but thank you for
using that and sharing your message and
yeah I hope that people grab grab this
idea to think differently about
themselves their time and yes and how
they can actually use it to serve other
people yes you know it is it's all about
like goodness you know and and glory to
God and glory to others and doing your
best if you measure for money you're
going to strive towards money if you
measure for time you'll get time but you
can measure for both you can have money
and meaning you can have time flow and
cash flow and when terrible things
happen you can assign meaning to that
terrible thing even if you haven't heard
a voice telling you what's good you can
assign positive meaning and choose to be
better not bitter and I think that's an
incredible mess so good hey so where
where can people find your book or and
and find you and what you do yeah thank
thank you my books everywhere it's all
the bookstores you know wherever they're
sold you get them in Barnes and Noble
um someone just told me they found out
on Fifth Avenue in in New York at Barnes
Noble I was like no way that's so
awesome I was like freaking out yeah it
was like a little kid like oh my gosh I
can't play it but yeah it's on Amazon
man just get on Amazon or go to
richnorton.com and go to Rich
norton.comtime and I have a free
Challenge and guide that helps you like
go step by step into creating these
systems for your own for your own life
awesome thank you so much thanks brother
that was awesome appreciate you
foreign